اذا ثمانيه اشهر مضت منذ قرر افلامير بوتن
شان الحرب على جارته الغربيه اوكرانيا
عداد الخسائر خسائر الطرفين يسابق الزمن
بل وتتجاوز تبعات الحرب اطرافها ووسط هذه
الحال تتعالى الاصوات المناديه بالعوده
الى طاوله المفاوضات منها اوروبيه عالميه
ومنها امريكيه السريه اشهدت الحرب الجميله
والدعم الغربي الا محدود لاوكرانيا بدا
يفقد بريقه فان اقتصادات الغرب تحت ضغط
التضخم وازمه الطاقه صحيفه واشنطن بوصل
الامريكيه تحدثت عن ان اداره
شجعت قاده اوكرانيا على التعبير عن
انفتاحهم للتفاوض مع روسيا والتخلي عن
رفضهم العلنيه للانخراطي في محادثات
السلامه نتذكر انه في اواخر سبتمبر الماضي
بعد ضم بوتن اربعه مناطق اوكرانيه لروسيا
اصدر زينسكي مرسوما يع انه من المستحيل
التفاوض مع الزعيم الروسي قال حينها
سنتفاوض مع الرئيس الجديد الصحيفه ذكرت ان
الطلب الامريكي لا يهدف الى دفع اوكرانيا
الى طاوله المفاوضات انما هي محاوله
محسوبه لضمان ان تحافظ كاف على دعم الدول
الغربيه نقلت واشنطن بوست عن مسؤول امريكي
رفض الكشف عنه هويته ان السبب الرئيسي
وراء الطالب الامريكي من كياف هو ان بعض
شركاء الولايات المتحده ارهقهم الدعم
الاكراني الديبلوماسي المخضرم الكسندر
فيربو الذي شغل منصب سفير واشنطن لدى
موسكو ونائب الامين العام للنت وقال انه
اذا اصبحت الظروف اكثر ملائمه للمفاوضات
فلا يعتقد ان الاداره الامريكيه ستكون
سلبيه لكنه اضاف انه في نهايه المطاف
الاوكرانيون هم من يقاتلون لذلك على
الولايات المتحده والغرب ان وحريصين على
عدم انتقادهم
[موسيقى]
لكن في الاسابيع الاخيره ازدادت حدثت
الانتقادات الاوكرانيه للتنازلات المقترحه
بشكل كبيره بل ووصل الامر الى حد وصفي من
ينادون بها بالحمقاء وبانهم يخدمون مصالح
الكراملين مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني بخيله
بدولاك قال يوم الجمعه اذا انتصرت روسيا ف
سنشهد فتره من الفوضى ازدهار للطغيان
والحروب والاباده الجماعيه والسباقات
النوويه اي تنازلات لبوتن اليوم ستكون
بمثابه صفقه مع الشيطان
ونتائجها مدمره يحجج المسؤولون
الاوكرانيون ويتسائلون عن سبب اختلاف اي
اتفاق سلام جديده عن سابقه يقولون ان
الطريقه الوحيده التي ستمنع بها روسيا من
العوده لمزيد من الهجمات هي هزيمه جيشها
في ساحه المعركه الرئيس الاوكرانيه اخبر
احد محاوره مؤخرا بان اول شيء سيفعله بعض
انتصار اوكرانيا في الحرب هو زياره شبه
جزيره القرم المحرره قال اريد حقا ان ارى
البحر لكن يبدو ان الغرب ووشن جادون
بالدفع نحن نحو المفاوضات التي ترى صحيفه
وسط جونل انها قد تنتهي الى صفقه قبيحه لا
تسمن ولا تغني من جوعا مالك تويتر الجديد
الماسك الذي دعمك بالانترنت الفضائي
الديمقراوات الديمقراطيون التقديميون وبعض
اعضاء مجلس النواب الامريكي بداوا يحضون
اداره بيضا على الضغط على اوكرانيا نحو
المفوضات وبالحديث عن الوساطات والمفاوضات
نستذكر محاولات الرئيس الفرنسي
زار موسكو وتحدث مرات ومرات مع بوت هاتفيه
محاولا التوصل الى احد فشلت جهوده في كل
مره قبل ايام اكد ان مفاوضات السلام
يقررها الاوكرانيون لكنه عاده وط من باب
الفاتيكان التدخل والتحدث مع بوتن وعرابي
كنيسته الارثوذكسيه كيريل
[موسيقى]